Here's something I'd like everyone to hear.
[Music]
Kanako Amemiya I've been struggling with how I should face you.
Don't cry, Kanako-chan.
If you're still going to cry, what should I do?
[Music]
If I don't, it will be like it never happened, so it's okay to
say it.
I know that Kanako-chan loves Hime-chan.
[Music] I
know that Hime-chan loves me. I
love you so much now, and I'm saying it out loud for the
first time.  I know
about Shita Hime-chan and Kanoko-chan
's love. If I had known, it wouldn't have happened.
I'm special to Kanako-chan.
What does that mean?
Congratulations on becoming Shvester with me.  Congratulations to all of you. I
think you two are a good match.
[Music] Please
don't get in my way. That's
why I'm going to be your sister.
[Music] Just
know that you can talk to me whenever you feel like crying.
[Music]  Music]
Thank you